skis à la nécessité pour un certain
nombre de ministres de porter plus haut
et plus fort l'exigence de justice
sociale à laquelle vous êtes sûrement
très sensible moi j'y suis très sensible
c'est le fondement de mon implication
sociale depuis toujours d'étranges été
délégué syndical c'était dans une
volonté de lutte que je me suis d'abord
engagée puis à prier la sagesse avec
l'âge mais cette lutte elle reste ou
alors sur des questions là la question
fondamentale effectivement est-ce que ce
message par les plus vrai au mieux pour
qui fait leur certains membres du
gouvernement vous d'autres on a parlé
des ministres issus de la gauche je sais
pas ce que c'est mieux il faut qu'on le
porte plus fort il faut qu'on le dise
plus régulièrement il faut qu'on le
montre plus régulièrement
et puis l'opposition aujourd'hui elle
nous attaquent plus sur nos mesures qui
seraient considérés comme étant des
mesures libérales économiquement et
moins sur ces mesures là est donc comme
on les attaque moins on en parle moins
c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas une droite
qui nous les reproches n'a pas une
gauche qui dévalorise donc effectivement
l'un dans l'ain elles sont complètement
mises elles sont pas elles ne sont pas
sûrs valorisé par la chambre d'écho que
peut représenter et les médias et
internet et les directions des lycées